you know just about five minutes up the
road is a naval station that were told
suffered significant damage but we have
not yet been allowed onto the property
see for ourselves up and down the state
California is spending about 16 million
dollars installing quake detection
sensors and yesterday we spoke with the
renowned seismologist dr. Lucy Jones who
many of you may have seen on TV over the
last few days and we started with the
one belief people have it turns out to
not be true I overheard a man say when
you have an earthquake like the one in
Ridgecrest it takes the pressure off and
lessens the likelihood of more like them
is that true unfortunately not that is
part of the human need to form a pattern
we hate randomness and the fundamental
is the distribution of earthquakes is
random seismologists Lucy Jones says the
recent earthquakes are sending a message
that an even bigger one is lurking this
is not the big one I say that the term
the big one you can only use if it's
such a big event you changed the nature
of society you know Katrina was the big
one for for New Orleans Maria in Puerto
Rico right though those are events
disasters that really change society if
an earthquake like Friday's were to hit
the city of Los Angeles
Jones estimates it could cause upwards
of two hundred billion dollars in
damages CBS News science and futurist
contributor Michio Kaku says the
likelihood of LA being hit by quote the
big one in the next 30 years is
inevitable if you had a seven point one
here in downtown Los Angeles what would
happen a lot more damage we have a lot
of buildings in the Los Angeles area
that were built before we had any
seismic building codes so especially
buildings built before the 1976 code are
the ones that were most concerned about
records at the California Department of
Insurance showed that just 13% of the
state's residents have insurance
policies with earthquake coverage
Ronnie Tolbert is not one of them
they're probably gonna have to rent a my
home Tolbert and her husband dan who is
disabled barely made it out when the
second quake hit she is not sure how
she's going to rebuild their home that
they lived in for 32 years
I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm kind
of old to start over I just lost my job
got laid up and so I don't know I don't
know what I'm gonna do
the Tolbert's are so worried that as I
speak to you now they are sleeping on a
mattress in their driveway some points
before we leave you some suggestions
three things number one have enough food
and water in your home to last you for
about three days come up with an
emergency contact that's in your home
that rescuers can find that has a
contact for someone out of state and
Anthony officials are telling us tell
people inside their homes secure items
on the wall like pictures TVs and even
the ceiling fan that can be invaluable
when you have another big quake all very
good advice David tough times for some
people out there thank you